I am over the moon I'm excited we won
already
and tonight's victory was unexpected
really I really love Humphrey
oh and I'm just excited I'm over the
moon it's a very good thing and I think
that we've already won you know whether
or not we win the Oscar yeah I do we
would love to win the Oscar but I think
that we won't because they've
acknowledged precious and I think that
that is in itself a it's very big with
myself I put a bed out with all of us
deserve to win we all that work very
hard and they're all different builds
they're all completely different worlds
and I've grown on this journey to
actually you know in production you have
a family this is my family this is my
production Beverly and then as we go on
the road on this campaign I wanna win so
it's a very bizarre incident and an
officer feeling yeah
usually during the Oscars I'm pissed off
that there's no new systems episode
Oh while the cameras were rolling we
were very much into the moment and Mary
and precious Nara in a fight and we were
in that fight on camera rolling but
she's such a lovely person and she's so
very different and I was so very
different approaches but as soon as mr.
Daniell said cut we love each other and
we have each other and I think I'm not
sure we were if we understood what we
were doing while we were doing it and
wasn't for me was it it wasn't clear how
different and how amazing the
participant was until after we saw and
it's just it really is a testament to
the genus of mr. Daniels he has the
power to transform people with
completely different personalities into
something on 109°
into a different character completely
something I know I wasn't asked this
question but for me there's something in
the DNA of this piece and that is the
invisible and finding out how remarkable
they are and there are people who work
in this filament that I failed to thank
you during my speech who without this I
don't think could have been there and
that's Lisa Cortez Tom color a scrum
stain they're right here
and as much a part of this film and as a
nameless and without them this this
doesn't happen so I just here they are
right here you gotta talk to the studio
again my agent
that's the agent get the money then the
studio get the money get my my kids get
the money and the IRS get a cut one last
question please what's for the best
party tonight I have a question for
Brian yes we are so glamorous and lovely
but in this show we had to really dress
down and stuff like that was that
awkward like something that you usually
are like Polly really took pride to the
Mariah no it was it was actually it was
horrible to even like standing and
lighting like this even bothers maybe
present has been trained that way from
nation you know doing videos or whatever
and so Lee knows that and so he took it
he's like brett ratner a friend of mine
another director sense to leave you put
her in a riot carry health so basically
he did things to torture me I didn't do
it and why I do and I wanted to do it
because I wanted to go there as an actor
so you know inside
as opposed to this is she marvelous I'm
wearing Spanx